[Music]  Montreal is a city of culture it's a  city of history it's a city whose name  it's like a big brown thing on the top  of the white stuff and then I think it's  kind of some cheese feel like I would  eat this like if I was right about to  hibernate this is what I would eat  literally 20 minutes ago and we were  doing this someone said are you baby  driver  I said yeah I've had a bunch of  interactions with strangers and it's  like a really nice way to be welcomed to  a city I'd say  [Music]  there's so much information out there  and at this point it seems like kind of  a Montreal is a ton of really great  restaurants why are we just eating 14 I  feel like it's like this doesn't really  matter  [Music]